you know i think everybody can see this
is moving very fast and this is highly
transmissible and the rates are going to
continue to go up
it's a period of the year when lots of
people have got things that really
matter to them uh family-wise also in
other bits their life and my point was
and i hope this uh i hope i can
reiterate this that um people want to
protect the time that is most important
to them and that does therefore mean in
practice it is sensible for people to
cut down on work or other
interactions with people including
potentially social ones which are less
important to them so that they they
reduce their chances of catching covid
and indeed reduce their chances of
passing it on i wouldn't want to um say
to people they should do a particular
thing they should do this or they should
do that this is about saying to people
look this is a period to prioritize and
that also to be clear was a message the
prime minister also uh said last night
so just to be a bit more specific dr
nikki kanani
yesterday advised people not to go to
football matches if it was to watch
football uh do you agree with that
what she was actually saying was if
someone went to a stadium please make it
an opportunity to have a boost and i
think that was a that's a message we
really seriously wanted to get to
obviously uh we want to get back to a
situation where we're back on a more
normal track and the route to that lies
through the booster program and what she
was saying is we are opening up stadia
over this weekend for boosting and her
positive message as someone very heavily
embedded in the in the boosting program
was please take your opportunity to get
boosting if that means going to a
stadium that really should be the
priority you're not advising people not
to go to football matches correct
what i'm advising people to do is to
prioritize uh if the most important
thing to them in the next 10 days is to
go to a football match that's the
priority for them that's really the
point i was trying to make but
prioritize the things that really matter
to you uh but don't uh but if you wish
to do those things and wish to do so and
not end up self isolating or unwell at
the time you really don't want to be
then you're probably going to want to do
fewer other things so if you were
planning in the the next week to go to
i don't know four or five social
functions uh your advice would be try
not to go to perhaps the two or three
that matter least to you
well certainly i mean obviously depend
what other social basically what i'm
saying is that anybody who has something
that really matters to them concentrate
on that thing and then build out from
there rather than just accepting every
invitation and going to every bit of
work
in person and this very much applies
also to work situations certainly our
team are way down in terms of the
numbers coming in that's quite right
most other teams are that i know and
that's very sensible government guidance
is work from home if you can and that
absolutely remains uh the guidance now
just to be
more specific on something that's going
on a lot at the moment which is
christmas parties and office christmas
parties i think what you're saying is
that if you're one of those people for
whom that kind of party is not essential
as compared to
spending time with your family for
example then that would be a good thing
not to go to
yeah i'm really trying to avoid and
you're trying to make me but i'm still
trying to avoid making other people's
choices for them but i would go on to
say really clearly that i think people
should prioritize what really matters to
them and then cut down on the things
that don't for some people it may be
that what really matters then is going
to the office party fine
but i think it really should be it
should be ready for people to make those
choices that's very clear and and
helpful thank you for that can i just
move on to some
more questions about omicron itself and
what we do know and what we don't know
now one of the things that you talked
about that we don't yet
really have
hard data on is the extent
to which vaccines will stop you getting
seriously ill
so
so far as i understand it's the studies
seem to show quite a lot of vaccine
escape after two doses but much less
after a third booster dose
could ask do those figures relate to
antibody deterioration and t cell
deterioration or is it just antibodies
there are two lines of evidence there's
the lab side of things and there's the
clinical side of things
and for all of these and i know you know
this chair but i'm laying it out for
people watching this there are kind of
three things we're interested in the the
ability of the vaccine to stop people
getting infected
uh the ability of the vaccine to stop
people getting severe disease in any
other hospital and the ability of the
vaccine to stop people dying and in
general
they get more and more effective as you
go up that line
now what we have at the moment on the
lab side is quite a lot of different
labs looking at the antibody data which
is half of the immune system as you
imply and that certainly suggests that
antibody response is much less effective
against this variant than it was against
delta and alpha and the original wuhan
strain
now that doesn't necessarily that that
is likely to translate into reduced
ability to reduce it infection
and that is indeed what we're seeing so
the clinical studies are showing that
lots of people are getting re-infected
with omicron who previously had been
vaccinated or
had a combination of vaccines and
natural infection so it definitely is
likely to bypass some of the ability to
reduce and
reduce infection
uh what we don't have is very good uh t
cell uh studies uh in the same ways we
do they take longer to do for one thing
from the lab side what we don't have is
clinical studies either from south
africa or the uk or anywhere else that
say to us with confidence
what the level of protection of two dose
of one dose two doses and a booster dose
are on hospitalization and deaths
now i think most people think on the
positive side we all think that
there will be some preserved
immunity particularly on the uh the
non-antibody side t cell and other side
and therefore it is likely that the
someone who's had one or two vaccines
already will have some protection with a
booster considerably more protection
against hospitalization and deaths even
though
the protection against uh infection is
less good and the final point i want to
make on the boosters is it does look as
if they restore some of the ability to
actually reduce infection probably quite
a lot of it actually at least for a
period of time and so there are um
multiple reasons to get the booster
it will reduce your risk of severity uh
it will reduce probably the risk of
mortality and it almost certainly will
reduce your risk of transmitting and
getting symptomatic disease so we really
want to push the point that boosters is
absolutely critical to this when do you
think we will get good data on
uh hospitalization rates and
risk of severe illness and death
i think we'll get some reasonable data
from south africa before we do from the
uk but that will be for two doses
because they haven't got a booster
program in the way that we have yet
uh and they will probably go first on
the clinical side but there's good data
coming here and i'll ask dr hopkins to
talk about that because uh uk hsa indeed
specifically droppings itself are
leading on this in terms of the booster
that will take longer obviously because
uh as of uh you know two weeks ago
almost nobody was boosted uh and now
we've got really high really good levels
in in the older population uh but we
haven't yet uh got all the way down to
the group which is actually being
infected by um by uh omicron uh susan do
you want to add to uh what i've said
yeah so we have a series of studies that
we have planned and our have the
analysis all ready to run
what we know is that we need about 250
individuals in hospital before we can
make a severity assessment uh compared
to uh delta
and also our vaccine effectiveness
assessment we start running that
assessment when we start having enough
cases who have been admitted to hospital
to do it and then we run it daily um
until we have enough power to determine
that the results are
effective to
allow us to be basically make um
assessments to release how many omicron
patients do we have in hospital as of
today or yesterday
so the release numbers that we released
yesterday are 15 however we are
constantly working on data linkage to
improve that and we will release new
numbers this afternoon
but the real number will be much bigger
than that that is simply the number who
have proven just to begin exactly
understood but just to give us all as
members of the public an idea of time
scales are you expecting to have some
reliable data in
before christmas in a week's time or is
it going to be
january before we really know the answer
to that question
i i think with the earliest that we will
have reliable data is the week between
christmas and new year and probably
early january